نظرًا لعدم السماح لنا بالعمل
والخروج من منازلنا ، فقد اضطررنا جميعًا إلى تسجيل
فيديو جديد لك ومن خلال هذا الفيديو
لنودعكم جميعًا ونطلب منكم أن
تبقونا في صلاتكم ، كان هذا فيديو وداعًا لنجمة صديقي
الآلاف من
متابعيها وداعًا للطريقة الوحيدة للحياة هذه
نجمة اليوتيوب الأفغانية البالغة من العمر 20 عامًا والتي
عرفت
جيلًا من النساء الأفغانيات تحت
حكم طالبان كانت قصة الماضي
قبل أيام فقط من سقوط
مدينتها كانت نجمة في الشوارع  من كابول ،
يمكنك بسهولة أن تعتقد أن هذا الثلاثي من
مراسلي اليوتيوب
بملابسهم الأنيقة البراقة خرجوا في
شوارع مدينة حديثة أخرى مثل
دبي أو الدوحة
مبتسمين يضحكون فقط
مستمتعين وكانوا يفعلون أكثر ما
تحبه في الحياة اليومية في مدينتها الحبيبة.
بعد أيام من سقوط كابول ،
سجلت هذا الفيديو
في كابول أصبح صعبًا للغاية
خاصة بالنسبة لأولئك الذين اعتادوا أن يكونوا
أحرارًا وسعداء ،
فنحن جميعًا داخل منازلنا
وليس لدينا القدرة والشجاعة
للذهاب إلى الخارج للعودة إلى العمل والعودة إلى
جامعاتنا ، لم نعد قادرين
على تسجيل البرامج والدراسة
على الرغم مما يقولون
إنه ليس لديهم أي مشاكل مع
الفتيات يمكن للفتيات أن يسعين للحصول على التعليم ، اذهب
إلى الجامعة والذهاب  للعمل ولكننا
سمعنا عن ماضيهم ، لم يعد بإمكاننا
الوثوق بهم للعودة إلى الجامعة أو
العمل بنوع من الشجاعة التي اعتدنا عليها أن
يكون لدينا المزيد
من الدارسين الذين كانوا يدرسون ليصبحوا
صحفية في عامها الأخير في
معهد الصحافة في كابول.  انضممت إلى
قناة الأفغان إنسايدر على اليوتيوب وهي وظيفة
أحبتها بوضوح ، لكن الأمر كان أكثر من مجرد
أن
معظم العائلات في المدينة
تنتظر فقط وجبة واحدة في اليوم للبقاء على
قيد الحياة الآن كنت أعمل لكسب ما يكفي
لدفع مصاريفي اليومية ومن أجل
تعليمي مثلي كان هناك فتيات
أخريات كن المعيلات
لأسرهن بأكملها ، وهن من
لم يكن لديهم أخ أو أب أكبر لإعالتهم ،
لكنهم الآن في
المنزل في انتظار الوضع المناسب.
يا صديقي العزيز ، ليس لدي القدرة على
التحدث بعد الآن ولا يمكنني القول بعد الآن
فقط ادعوا من أجلنا نصلي من أجلنا
ألا نبتعد كثيرًا عن آمالنا
وأحلامنا ويمكننا أن نصبح الفتيات نحن
كنا قبل ذلك يمكننا أن نكون سعداء مرة أخرى
بارتداء الملابس التي أحببناها مرة أخرى
ولكن مع انهيار عالمها ، كان عليها أن
تخرج قبل فوات الأوان
في اليأس ،
انضم شقيقها وابن عمها إلى آلاف آخرين في
مطار كابول يحاولون الهروب من حياة
بدون  الكثير من الأمل في
أنهم لم يتمكنوا من تحقيق ذلك ،
كان الثلاثة من بين أكثر من 170
شخصًا فقدوا في هجوم يوم الخميس القاتل
، الكلمات المؤلمة في فيديو الوداع
الآن أكثر من مجرد وداع للحرية ،
أتمنى أن يكون حلمًا سيئًا يا إلهي
أتمنى أن نستطيع  استيقظ يومًا
ما أو استيقظ شخص ما قائلاً
اشرب كوبًا من الماء لقد حلمت بحلم سيء
لكنني أعلم
أنه غير ممكن
[موسيقى]
وأنه حقيقة أننا انتهينا